uh have you ever been on a dating app I  have how did that go okay mixed I mean  you know it's you can put your hand in a  bag and take it out and you'll get a  different response all the time but the  last time I went on one I mean I was  dating this guy for a period of time but  I friend zoned him quite quickly I mean  we didn't have  I wasn't attracted to him  and yeah there wasn't anything to him  he's a nice guy but just not for me but  you know I dated him for a period of  time but I mean one lesson that I  learned is don't friends on them and if  they're not if they're just not how can  I say if you're not attracted to them  there's no point in being with them so  just just don't do it I mean I've  learned the hard way so yeah